you've been with your husband how many
how many years have you been together
been together for 13 years Wow good for
you am I correct that your husband has
given you a free pass now sometimes that
means for a lot of couples that can mean
like a celebrity you get a free if you
happen to meet that celebrity you get to
get it oh I'm curious you have a free
pass who's your free pass I do it's my
free pass you ready for this
it is any I get there could be a lot of
them any of the teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles any which one I so choose wait
wait how does that work I'm just curious
because they don't really exist
you're really shattering a dream yeah
sorry
nobody is it he's went ahead of us come
about how did you just said he just you
you obviously love Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle I saw when I saw the billboard
for it I was like they look pretty hot
and he was like well that that's it
that's your that's your Hall Pass any
one of them I think at this point though
like I know it's not gonna happen and
you know maybe it'll be like just a guy
on Hollywood Boulevard like dressed as a
mutant you're going I'll take that guy
no don't take that guy
do not take that guy that doesn't go
that does not go well
trust me good guy I spent six weeks with
a spider-man and it was a disaster
don't do it
you